that if you get focused and disciplined
and you really know what you're doing
you pick a proven and profitable niche
and you build it around your strengths
you could be earning a six-figure income
doing something you absolutely love
teacher astronaut soldier banker when i
say these different types of careers you
know exactly what i'm talking about but
what happens when i say youtuber or
content creator it gets a little more
fuzzy if you're at thanksgiving with
uncle joe right well in today's episode
we're gonna be breaking down what it
actually takes to be a full-time content
creator because did you know that a
study just came out that said content
creators are one of the fastest growing
small business types right now my name
is heather torres and i am your host of
the think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow your influence
on youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
youtube channel and i am so excited that
you are here today and if today is your
first time listening to the podcast i
want to say welcome if you're new here
you can subscribe to make sure you don't
miss an episode because we are dropping
more and more content every single week
so stay locked in and loaded for that
and today's episode is brought to you by
a couple special things we're doing here
at think media number one is we are
giving away a brand new youtube studio
yes this means camera lighting
microphone and so much more and in order
to enter we would love for you to fill
out a simple survey for us it takes
about five minutes over at win this
tech.com you can fill out that survey be
entered in to win this amazing giveaway
and maybe that will be showing up at
your doorstep for this holiday season
and the second announcement is that we
are hiring here at think media you can
go to workwiththink.com to get all the
details of the new job roles that we
have available for you as well as a new
internship program that we are starting
so if that sounds like something right
up your alley you can go to work with
think dot com for all of the details all
right let's get into today's featured
content where we are breaking down the
data the facts and pulling back the
curtain on what it takes to be a
full-time content creator
[Music]
so how much money are full-time
youtubers really making how long does it
take from starting your channel to
actually earning a decent living i'm so
excited to dive into this new study that
reveals actual data not someone's
opinion from part-time and full-time
content creators so we can discern some
details to help us navigate our journey
to building a full-time
income and business that makes a
difference in people's lives and also
makes significant income for our
families so let's dive right into it but
i kind of want to open with a question
for you and it's have you ever had this
question
what is it exactly you do
now maybe that's kind of a funny
question no matter what because
sometimes you might work in a specific
industry that if you go to like a family
gathering like they don't really
understand what you do so you're trying
to figure out like you're like i don't
know i'm the vp of operations of a
biotech niche you know like maybe people
don't understand well how much more true
is that when it comes to you being a
youtube creator like have you ever been
you know you're driving in an uber i
know that happens to me i'm in like a
lift and someone's like so they go yeah
so uh so where you headed i'm like ah to
a conference they go oh what do you do
and i'm like uh
uh and i get stuck
um
i'm a youtuber i usually say i'm like
i'm in marketing or i say uh i i run a a
media
what i say we we do video production
because there's so many things you
actually do as a youtuber you could say
yeah i'm in video production or i'm in
content marketing or i'm in digital
marketing right how do you answer the
question and then furthermore if you say
hey i'm a youtuber like what does that
even mean they're like oh you're like
ryan's toys reviews
you you you open like shopkins on on
youtube on the youtube kids app like
there's like a million definitions is it
pewdiepie are you a gamer
usually you're not taken seriously as an
entrepreneur or business owner a
business owner isn't really a youtuber
and this gets into this idea that this
study kind of hits on
about it's it's the largest study that i
know of of content entrepreneurs they
studied
1400 entrepreneurs to understand who
they were what they aspire to do what it
takes to build a successful business and
you can actually we'll link to it
the study is at thetilt.com and shout
out to the crew over there for putting
this study together half of the
respondents were full-time as a content
creator half were part-time and they're
mixed across gen z millennials gen x and
boomers and one of the initial goals was
kind of a definition of terms
that really a content entrepreneur or
what we're calling them think media is a
youtube entrepreneur niching down kind
of even more the study is covering
people that might be on blogging
podcasting you know maybe another social
platform or youtube but i think the
principles are 100 transferable to
youtube solely and specifically
um they're they're kind of saying okay
you're really not a youtuber number one
and did you know this i looked this up
you can go at least on google and
youtuber is on webster it's in webster's
dictionary the definition is a person
who creates and uploads videos
on youtube
on the youtube online video sharing
service you're like
well that's not helpful i mean that's a
lot of different things so that's what
youtuber is they also there's this
introduction of another term called the
creator economy the creator economy it's
like the biggest buzzword right now like
oh you're part of the creator economy
like what does that even mean and
another synonym for it is the passion
economy like oh yeah these are people
who make a living by creating content so
what is the creator economy well it's
defined as a class of businesses built
by over 50 million
independent content creators curators
and community builders including social
media influencers bloggers and
videographers plus the software and
finance tools designed to help them with
growth and monetization
that's
the
large and somewhat ambiguous creator
economy and so when we think about a
youtube entrepreneur it's not just
necessarily a youtuber creating silly
content
or a tick talker dancing around in the
creator economy it's something different
so the question is is the goal to become
a content creator
or is the goal to become a content
entrepreneur
right and what are the distinctions
of
what makes a content entrepreneur
you know this study from thetilt.com
really described it said content
entrepreneurs aren't who they think you
are uh they aren't who you think they
are banish the image of under 30 viral
youtube and tick tock stars the largest
and most financially successful core
cohort in this study was gen x 40 of
people in the study
who are now in their 40s and 50s now
that right there would probably shock
you first of all you go to a christmas
party you know with your family and and
you say you're a youtuber and they're
like oh you dance to music oh you you
post cat videos like cute you know like
that that's just the assumption secondly
they probably don't think
that
it's 40 and 50 year olds that are
crushing it and what this study
discovered was these are the real
channels that are actually funding
they're generating the most profit and
revenue in terms of the creator economy
because certainly you can create
entertainment based kind of viral
content earn money with adsense but to a
point a lot of those viral trends come
and go
these creator uh these content
entrepreneurs youtube entrepreneurs
they're building different they're
building a real business as one person
explained
please don't consider people don't
consider it a real business because they
think about instagram influencers and
youtubers doing silly stuff
content creation covers a lot
more than most people think including
business blogging and education
so i want to cover 10 things that this
study revealed i highly recommend
downloading it and checking out the
offerings of the tilt.com really
grateful that they did this study
because i think this will help us
navigate
really uh
how to make this a full-time thing
how to make youtube our career how to
make it how to work on our own terms how
to work from home and what it might
disrupt is our mindset of how we thought
we were going to do it it might actually
disrupt our definition
and even really putting handles on this
real career path in the past you'd
probably say i know it's kind of wild
west it's getting a little more solid
now like the path to full-time freedom
on youtube is defined like it's it's
becoming defined by studies like this
and you're saying okay there is a method
to this but it's maybe not what i think
it's maybe
not
what i conceived before and this data
will help us put handles to that number
one
truth about the most successful
youtube entrepreneurs number one they
work on their content business full-time
they work on their content business
full-time now what you might be saying
is you might be like well obviously
like of course the most successful ones
do it full-time i wish i could work on
it full-time that's the point sean i
thought you said how do i work on you
know i i want to do that eventually but
i got a full-time job right now i got
school i got work i got responsibilities
i get it
but you know what this first discovery
reveals to me
it reveals that when you approach
youtube
as a youtube entrepreneur and not
as a youtuber you're approaching it with
a whole nother dimension
of focus and discipline right you're
approaching it with a mentality that oh
i'm not actually just like a content
creator i'm a business owner i'm a ceo
i'm building a business i need to think
about the systems of this the
practicality of this the
viability of this i need to kind of
think about sales operations and
marketing i'm throwing a lot of savatcha
but that's a whole different approach
like you go to you know that
thanksgiving party and you're hanging
out with uncle ernie and he's like oh so
you're a youtuber over there you're like
no i'm a business owner ernie
i got i mean i got p l profit loss i got
it's a different mentality like no i'm
building like a media
content creation company
and
a separate study by signal fire revealed
that this is the fastest growing type of
small business
my question for you is do you think
yourself as a business owner or do you
think yourself with just a youtuber
so on number one here they work on their
content business full time the research
shows that those who are invested full
time are more likely to be financially
independent than those who treat it as a
gig and this makes sense growing a
successful venture takes focus and
discipline
so
my encouragement to you is that even if
you're in that side hustle season
flip your mentality from it being just a
gig and flip your mentality to full time
by the way your time you maybe only have
five hours a week ten hours a week to
work on your youtube business
be focused and disciplined with those
hours
be thinking differently about building
your side it's kind of almost like some
people call it a side hustle it's like
it's not a hustle it's a side business i
only have a few hours each week to
invest in it so i'm going to be really
serious and focused with those hours
number two
content entrepreneurs aren't who you
think they are
banish the image of under 30 viral
youtuber tick tock stars the largest and
most financially successful
cohort in this study was gen x 40 in the
study
now these people are in their 40s and
their 50s
now we read that before but the point is
i hope this is good news for you to
think okay by the way all generations
are succeeding but what's dispelling the
myth is that if you're in your legacy
years you're not too late in fact
if your gen x baby boomers are in this
study as well think of all the business
acumen you have the experience that you
have the wisdom that you have and see
this also as an invitation to see that
this is already happening
people just like you this is what we've
discovered people from different
backgrounds ethnicities ages
locations
everybody has a chance to succeed on
youtube because you can go find someone
who looks like you sounds like you has
your background in your experience right
now succeeding on the platform
and if you can find one person who's in
your same situation a similar situation
that person should be an invitation to
say oh it's possible it's not just for
this type of person or this generation
or this age group or somebody with great
dance skills that can really get it on
to a beat of the latest trending song on
youtube shorts
that's not who's really crushing it when
it comes to
youtube entrepreneurship number three
lean in
seo
is the top tactic for content
entrepreneurs
now to me this is a major distinction
that shows us the pathway to full-time
freedom
and
what this reveals
is that
they're creating search-based content
but hear me even if it's not about say
just ranking in search
because the point is on youtube 75 of
traffic comes from recommendations
but what this being their top traffic
source reveals
is it reveals that these are channels
that solve a problem
so i would i would say that
predominantly these are channels that
are in the education niche
it does not mean they're not
entertaining in fact the best content
entrepreneurs
do edutainment you should make your
videos interesting or storytell or
unpack but
but you're solving a problem because
think about the term even entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs
solve problems for a profit if you're
gonna build a real business
you sell toothpaste to help people keep
their teeth clean if you're gonna build
a real business you sell a meditation
app like headspace to help people
declutter their mind and relax at the
end of the day or get their focus back
if you sell supplements or food and hear
me like i even think about think media
we help people build their influence
with online videos specifically i grew
the channel with the one main vehicle
was camera review videos what's the best
camera for youtube as a problem
there's products being sold the cameras
i am actually kind of like a middleman
because i just get the affiliate income
in the middle but i'm solving a specific
problem
you can go the path of having millions
of views and entertainment and making
money off youtube adsense absolutely
but for this study
seo is the top tactic
which is how people grew their audience
now the number two top tactic was
hashtags now obviously hashtags are most
relevant on instagram but what does that
reveal the same truth
that you are
gathering in search based interest bit
you're creating interest based content
so people start following yoga hashtags
they might be a good customer for a yoga
app yoga blocks
cool lululemon
yoga leggings you know the water bottle
the full thing is there a business model
around the industry see hashtags point
to industries
seo points to industries i can't sleep
at night i'm dealing with chronic pain i
need help with my taxes i need help with
this or that there could be supplements
there could be sleep tools there could
be books that give you tips tips on
understanding sleep there could be books
on how to buy and flip properties right
seo is the top tactic and hashtags was
number two for these content
entrepreneurs these youtube
entrepreneurs that's a huge insight
in maybe
how are you positioned what niche are
you picking what's your channel all
about number four here's the top
industries of this particular category
of creators the biggest one 19 is
business
second is marketing so the top two are
people helping people solve business
problems the second one helping people
solve marketing problems the next one
education next health and fitness nine
percent lifestyle is seven percent by
the way lifestyle is one of those ones
that we get into on youtube where like
i'm a lifestyle creator fair but like
what does that mean and it could mean
like yeah i mean i help people like i
put drops in my coffee in the morning
like cbd drops they're delicious and
then you know like i'm just kind of
lifestyle i like travel and i but it's a
thing but by the way it's seven percent
in terms of these youtube content
entrepreneurs right
arts and crafts and diy is on there
three percent entertainment science and
tech travel and events and cooking food
now
if your niche was not just listed it
doesn't mean that you can't thrive as a
youtube entrepreneur but success leaves
clues so there's something about saying
okay here's the these are the top 10
industries that were actually in this
study again half of these 1400 people
are full time the other half are already
part time and earning money and so this
goes into the idea again have you chosen
the right niche have you chosen the
right channel topic have you chosen a
proven and a profitable niche number
five the study revealed
they have a business mindset
they're focused on the financials and
the structure of the content business
how to monetize how to diversify how to
build an asset rather than a cult of
personality and content creation isn't
how they spend the majority of their
time
see
this is a whole different mindset
most people that want to be youtubers
right and you're in the uber what do you
do i'm a youtuber oh
i know i watch pewdiepie oh i've heard
of those i heard of the paul brothers i
hate those guys like like you know
that's cult of personality and that's
cool here's what i want to encourage you
just be like self-aware be more bold and
more confident in what exactly it is you
want to build who do you want to be what
is your goal what what what do you want
to be in the future
and i suppose if you're like no i
literally want to build a cult well
that's kind of weird uh but like but
but uh but
these
youtube entrepreneurs
content entrepreneurs are not on a
mission to build a cult of personality
they're on a mission to solve a problem
and serve people
they're on a mission also to build an
asset because
i mean in my opinion and by the way i've
been potentially early on i saw youtube
i'm like whoa
small town kid like i could actually i
could get like lots of views like people
would watch me i i'm glad that i
actually matured past that grew past
that because now i'm like i actually
kind of want to be less known i want
thick media to be more known i don't
know if i care if sean gets known but
i'll tell you this because if we all win
then we win and i'll win even bigger and
everyone with me will win even bigger
that's an asset that's a company that's
a movement that's just what kind of what
we're doing so that's a business mindset
like a really smart business owner is
not trying to build a business on
himself
that that's it's too heavy smart
business owner is trying to build an
asset and something bigger
than
themself
that's interesting distinction
and most successful content
entrepreneurs diversify their revenue
streams
so again we're not just leaning in i'm
gonna get a million views and youtube
will pay me and take care of all my
needs that's cool
but content entrepreneurs oftentimes
have multiple income flows
and
number six they now this is interesting
they only spend 30 percent of their time
creating content each week
30 percent
well sean what do they do the other 70
that's actually a really good question
to ask if you're unsure
for building maybe something different
than you're building right now like if
you're not getting the results you're
getting right now
then maybe you need to do something
different
and
for the youtuber they'd probably say my
number one job is to just make youtube
videos forget everything else
and again that is a path
but for the content entrepreneur again
they're thinking about
man how am i going to monetize am i
building out products am i am i really
setting up strategic brand relationships
am i building out a team around this is
there systems around this what are they
doing with the other 70 of their time
are they writing a book are they
building out something they can sell
they're writing an ebook are they
creating an online course
are they managing an online course
answering social media making
connections going back and forth in
audio dms with somebody on instagram off
platform because they're cultivating
that relationship that could turn into
business are they fulfilling on coaching
or consulting there's a lot of things
you could do
as a youtube entrepreneur and the study
revealed
that literally only 30 of their time was
spent in content creation that means you
might want to shift your calendar around
into real business building activities
number seven
the median amount
full-time content entrepreneurs invest
in their content business this is the
amount of money they spent
to start their business
get their business going
was ten thousand dollars
that number might shock you
1400 people studied though part-time and
full-time the average these content
entrepreneurs spent was ten thousand
dollars it doesn't shock me i mean i
think about my
investment over the last few years of my
life really 2010 to 2015 which i did not
have much to show in terms of revenue or
growth i was making progress even
creating momentum but i was in a
preparation season investing thousands
actually just in my learning i was
buying cameras and lenses and i buy a
light kit but i was buying plane tickets
i was buying event tickets i was buying
online courses
i
have a voracious
addiction
to books i to this day i bought it
buying books investing so
it's actually not surprising to me where
that 10k
is allocated is different and here's the
cool thing about this industry is of
course you can get started with your
smartphone but this goes back to kind of
like number one these content
entrepreneurs are full-time they're
serious they're focused and disciplined
they're putting their money where their
mouth is they're saying okay i'm not
trying to play
small potatoes here i'm actually going
to step up and build something you know
you can build a crazy quote-unquote
battle station aka a workstation at
think media we call them battle stations
you could get a standing desk and two
monitors and a camera and a lighting kit
and a live stream studio and a usb mic
and some software for five grand or less
like
subscribe to our think media channel we
have a whole series coming out on
building out battle stations we already
have tons of videos up there on
different ways to do it at different
budget levels
and then in addition to that you could
get
courses or coaching or education to help
you go further faster because this is a
real business right and so that's the
median amount that these this is what
the study revealed um that means some
spent more some spent less and check
this out the majority didn't take on
debt
i think this is exciting the majority
didn't have lean heavily into credit
cards or they didn't get funding or they
didn't take out a loan you could do that
i guess but i'm gonna really call you
out here i understand empathetically we
have a global audience and maybe there's
different economies
but if ten thousand dollars scares you
you might not be cut out for this
because any if you're listening to this
on a nice smartphone i'm just i want to
encourage you you can raise ten thousand
dollars you can save ten thousand
dollars you could set aside the money
you don't need it all at once you're
chipping away like you can get the money
like stop buying dumb stuff
like take some time
like try to get a raise
divert your funds from somewhere else
downsize your living get rid of that car
payment like when you think about
different people who give financial
advice
there's there's people i know that help
people get out of debt people kill 65
000 of debt in a matter of months
because they get
gazelle intensity and go after that debt
you can come up with ten thousand
dollars
and if you're worried about the ten
thousand dollars how are you going to
handle the company and the youtube
business that you build
so i want to encourage you
you don't have to take on debt to get
there like get focused get disciplined
figure out the tools you need the path
the things you want that you need help
on the journey and don't be afraid to
invest because that's what the
successful
full-time by the way
content entrepreneurs that's how much
the full time of this study invested
number eight how long does it take to
build the business this is cool so sean
how long
like setting
my focus getting disciplined
and starting this
and i quote on average
ces
con content entrepreneurs need 26 months
from launch to supporting a single
person from their revenues
now i believe this means
it's actually 26 months until
they're fully supporting themselves like
one whole person can be supported
from
the business
wow
so how long does it take 26 months
here's the breakdown
day zero launch
nine months they've earned their first
dollar
18 months they've hired help
and this is interesting because in the
past episode on the think media podcast
i did recommend hiring help before you
yourself are even full-time
like to start like you hire an editor
you hire you use a service like you know
vid chops to edit your videos or you
hire a personal assistant a virtual
assistant and then 26 months more than
two years
is when
they were supporting somebody fully this
path to profitability and financial
success
interestingly enough because you might
go wow that kind of puts things into
perspective
is actually shorter though than the
typical small business
so can i talk straight with you about
the opportunity here
i think again we think oh my gosh
26 months i don't even know if i want to
do this anymore well then you probably
shouldn't
the full-time people have invested
thousand dollars man i thought this was
gonna be easy i thought i could just
well then you might this might not be
for you
because if you put this in perspective
if you were to start a local brick and
mortar business like a local coffee shop
you're gonna have to raise money or take
out a small business loan to buy a
multi-thousand dollar espresso machine
to hire baristas because you can't work
the thing seven days a week the
full-time yourself to hire people to do
the cash register and get the ipad with
the flip around thing with a little
stripe inside insert your card here
email the receipt or print the receipt
you're gonna have to get the thing to
print the receipt unless you can't
because i go can you print it and they
go oh we don't even have that i'm like
why did i have the option was the point
of pressing the button and ultimately
why am i even printing receipts i'm
affecting the environment let's focus
you now have to pay for the office space
rather the least business space you
can't sign a 12-month lease you got to
sign a 24-month 36 month lease to get a
good price
you're opening up this coffee shop you
go to a marketing company to get the
signage the signage has like the little
neon lights in it and it needs to be
weatherproof so it lasts that thing
costs like a couple grand
you you got to get some merch done so
that all your baristas have like the
shirts like think about starting a
business
so the fact that this is a real business
the fastest growing small business type
that potentially the seed capital to
start a youtube entrepreneur business is
only ten thousand dollars and it will
only take you 26 months until you can
support yourself full-time that's even
faster than your typical small business
hear me
i get it is it guaranteed even that
you're going to succeed i'm not saying
that that that it is
i'm just saying
sometimes we're actually
underestimating the opportunity is it
going to be 26 months of hard work yeah
for sure well some people that's the
median time is some people a lot faster
yeah and it's some people will it take
longer yes
do some people invest more or lose money
on the process or whatever of course
but hear me like do you see how real
this opportunity is
like how incredible this is that
literally people from home are able to
start a real business
get these tools create this learn these
skills and here's number nine where it
really gets interesting
well then sean when they're supporting
one person how much are they bringing in
here's what the study figured out for
the full-time content creators
again it was 1400 people studied and
about half of them so this is 700
real full-time content entrepreneurs
full-time content entrepreneurs
are earning 50 000 a year that's the
median gross revenue and i'm that's
based in the u.s
so based on this study to put in
perspective
first thing you might say is
wow i mean my current salary at my
business the company i work for is more
than that yeah but
do you have the independence and the
lifestyle and are you doing what you you
love you might like
but so that's that was one of the main
drivers of content entrepreneurs is like
is the freedom but hear me
you got to have a vision for the future
because the full-time ones we're making
50k median gross revenue
watch this
with four or more years of experience
it goes up to a hundred thousand dollars
a year
and with seven or more years of
experience it goes up to a hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars a year
what's cool is i hope that this study
has been illuminating
but now let's paint that whole picture
so i'm like okay wow
it's going to take me two years
to potentially based on this study
support myself fully maybe i'm earning
50k now
and then
add five more years and seven years into
this thing i'm earning 125 k a year and
let's amplify that with inflation seven
years from now i don't even know like
the algorithmic calculation but you get
what i'm saying
this is very real and these show you the
real numbers is there crazy youtube
millionaires out there like that's the
unicorn stories of course
is there also some that are just
building a nice side income and they're
able to like take their family on nicer
vacations and earn an extra 5 100k a
year of course
but this is a very real business and
this this study kind of demystified the
mystique around it that if you get
focused and disciplined
and you really know what you're doing
you pick a proven and profitable niche
and you build it around your strengths
that's seven years from now you could be
earning a six figure income
practically
doing something you absolutely love
which brings us to number ten
lifestyle freedom and independence are
the primary motivators of ces i'm
curious what your motivators are but i
wouldn't be surprised because this is a
lot like me and i assume it's a lot like
you
the primary motivators of why do i want
to do this
is the biggest one 78 percent said
independence
these content entrepreneurs these
youtube entrepreneurs are fiercely
independent you know we don't we don't
want to work in that necessarily typical
nine-to-five corporate environment
commute to work every day we want to be
in a place where we have freedom we are
able to be creative
uh 73
the ability to pursue their passions
so would you be willing to give up i i
believe you can hit all of your wildest
financial targets but i think there's
another option you might be being like
man my 80k your salary is really
comfortable well would you take 60 to be
able to do be a youtube entrepreneur
full time and do what you want by the
way
maybe in the short term would you be
able to go down to zero quote unquote
lean into your savings to build out the
business for a couple years because it's
going to take two years to either build
it on the side or hustle and then start
scaling up the money so that you could
pursue your passion 69 said so that's
you had flexible work hours
60 said so that you would actually enjoy
your work hours
these are the reasons and the benefits
of being a content entrepreneur 59 said
so they could challenge themselves maybe
you're like my job's kush man got the
money it's kind of cool
um you know i like it's all right i
don't love my boss he's all right i'm
you know people i work with are they're
cool
but but here's one of the things we need
as humans to be to live a fully charged
life
we need challenge
see we're not shrinking back from
challenge challenge is when life gets
interesting
and it's a whole you step out onto the
waters he called me out upon the waters
right you caught you step out on the
waters when you start your own business
of being a youtube entrepreneur it's
challenging but it's also exciting
if that's your ambition
if that's what you want to do
43 to earn more than a traditional job
43 said to choose where i can live
content entrepreneurs agreed that you
have location freedom if you have an
internet connection you can really do
this job this career
for more time with my family and friends
more time to pursue my hobbies and
ultimately to prove myself to
others
so
ultimately
how much do youtubers earn
it's a whole range but this is pretty
accurate you'd be
stunned
by the long tail of people earning 35 50
80 100 125 and beyond per year
as youtube entrepreneurs and how do you
make youtube your job well i hope you're
subscribed to the think media podcast
stay connected with us in this community
because that's our mission we want to
help 10 000 purpose-driven people create
a full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with youtube and online video
my my story was i
started shooting videos in my bedroom i
started shooting
videos from my church in 2003 so i knew
about cameras i self-taught and video
lenses i started a media production
business so i took the thing that i had
learned and the mistakes i had made and
i started to do tech reviews and
tutorials on youtube around cameras
lenses what's the best camera for
creating content what's the best
microphone
early videos that did really well best
video editing laptop how to change an
ssd drive for the hybrid drive in my
toshiba laptop got like thousands and
thousands of views with an affiliate
link and i was able to earn money that
way because i was solving a specific
problem that was my journey i built a
six figure income myself and now myself
in the think media team are on this
mission to say hey we've learned a lot
on the way made a lot of mistakes on the
way and we believe we can help you get
there further faster
in your journey of if you want
becoming a youtube entrepreneur so stay
locked in with us in this community i
hope this episode served you and i can't
wait to see you
or hear you or you hear me on the
podcast in the next one
well i hope that featured content was
great for you and i have a couple
takeaway questions that i want to ask
first off what is your next step do you
need to think bigger invest more and
lean in more into where you want to grow
here's the big one do you actually just
need to get serious
is it time for you to step out outside
of your comfort zone and go all in on
youtube these are just some questions
for you to take away from today's
episode and i want to thank you for
being a part of the think media
community on every single episode we
love to shout out different members who
have rated and reviewed the podcast over
on apple podcast and today's community
member shout out is brought to you by
win this tech.com we are giving away a
brand new youtube studio so all you need
to do is go over and fill out a simple
survey that will help us know what
videos you want us to make in the future
by doing that you'll be entered in to
win a brand new youtube studio that is
the lighting the camera and so much more
that'll be sitting on your doorstep if
you win this holiday season the
community member shout out comes from
boy is a chicken over on apple podcast
what a cool name if you rate and review
the podcast you might be featured on a
future episode and this is what boy is a
chicken said why
how are they so amazing i can't wait to
start off the right way for my youtube
channel this is knox tucker p.s you guys
are the best think media well thank you
so much knox for leaving that review and
i decided that i wanted to also shout
out our youtube fam you know this
podcast not only can you listen to it on
anywhere that podcasts are distributed
but we also video record this podcast
for you and put it on our youtube
channel the think media podcast so the
comment of the day is brought to you by
work with think that is where you can go
if you would like to be hired on to our
team here at think media we have several
positions that we are hiring for right
now as well as a paid internship so you
can go to workwiththink.com
to get all the details to see if the
positions are right for you and the
youtube comment of the day is from
markhari b
she says i love listening to your wisdom
sean thanks a lot for all the info well
mar thank you so much for being a part
of our community and i'm so grateful
that you spent the time to rate review
the podcast and leave comments for us it
is so fun for me every single week to go
in there and be able to talk to you
through the comments on youtube well
thank you so much for listening today i
hope that you will take this content to
heart and we'll catch you in the next
episode bye
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success
we've helped thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs just like you grow their
influence with video register today for
this exclusive training at
thinkmasterclass.com
you